[Music]
everyone welcome to puzzlers Paris so
I'm gonna basically just give you guys a
bunch of puzzles I'm mostly gonna try to
stay out of the way but now and then I
might give you a few tips on how to
solve it if you get stuck I'm gonna try
to give you different types of puzzles
most of they're gonna be tactical some
will be in the end game but they're all
gonna be tactics for the most part so
start with this one so white to play I'd
say when you think you have the answer
not to many of you but raise your hand
just for good form and make sure it's
complete like usually it's not gonna be
just one move I want like variations and
want to make sure you see everything so
yeah
okay
okay very nice so yeah the king of a is
pretty easy to hear here so there's
black of any defense not really right I
mean takes here is gonna be pretty
deadly well maybe I could try and move
like this but yeah
Queen takes up seven is probably pretty
easy rook takes probably works basically
the key is that first of all you have to
look for all your checks right temple
moves Bishop h7 and also you know the
key is to figure out what the you know
what is holding blacks position together
once you eliminate this Bishop nothing
holds the Kings side together also like
these are all way to me and again try
not try to let everyone else think until
you have that until you think you have
Lansing so this is the key you want to
make sure you go to the end of your
variations it's easy to kind of jump on
it like I got it all but make sure you
see all the moves right because imagine
if you were to just bang down this and
then you were like oh my hands which are
it is but as was pointed out 52 and
there's actually no way to stop me so
you have to sack the Queen for the
bishop
yeah I mean but the point is that you
lose your whole queen like you have to
take this bishop you can throw in a
check if you want or play King of fates
but basically this is pretty easily one
too much material very nice yeah I call
a move like big 52 I have a name for it
well it's not my name I should say but
no I
it's the Stinger at the end of the tail
it looks like this variation doesn't
work but then you see Bishop you to and
it changes the evaluation
sure I mean not literally well anyway so
yeah the idea is that there's the maple
at you can't really stop it with the
Queen white to play you've seen it
before then hand up then hand down this
is a bit of a tricky one because I bet
you if you were to just look at this
position you'd probably think why would
there be a tactic here it's just some
endgame sure the knight on c4 is hanging
but so isn't there anyone like why would
there be a tactic so I'd say that
especially during your games like in end
games I find that people tend to forget
that tactics exist sometimes they just
play hmm
so to complete my thought there what I'm
saying is just that people forget that
there are tactics and end games so being
on the lookout tactically is important
no matter what phase of the game all
right that's all right hand here yeah
very nice theater miss moves like this
especially during a game because you
have to be on the lookout all the time
but the idea is is the temple move right
you always look at temple moves first
hitting the bishop the nights hanging
must take and then 92 and now your two
pieces hanging and there is no good
solution for those
yep
okay
okay is that the only variation
aha so you have to make sure that you
see all the lines before you jump at it
right so if after rook c8 the best you
can do after rook takes is take it's
probably not the best move yeah aha
so look see it so at the moment Queen f8
is a pretty strong threat there's no
world ready to stop it apart from taking
this route because if you take the pawn
or play Queen f6 can't really stop it so
you must take and now queenie soon so
you're hitting the so you're threatening
to take and take as well as da yeah
because what I would say so what choices
does black happen yeah
a rook you have to be cute you can't
just promote to a queen I understand
okay
I would promote to a clean air so queen
a5 for example you just promote right
you don't take a look and after look g8
which i think is the best move you
promote this time a queen is advisable
and you can't take back the Queen you
don't get a checkmate because black move
yeah it's gonna be pretty question
well so yeah the bishop retreat you
can't you just crash through and you
have rook c7 you take c6 this is gonna
be painful we must capture Queen a3 only
move Bishop e5 look things be fun
discovering on the Queen pretty much you
have to take or move away yeah this one
I found a lot of people can get stumped
on this one because it doesn't look like
you have anything to crushing but if you
force yourself to always look at temple
moves and the attacks captures checks
etc a4 has to be on your list right
because it's an attacking move which
means it deserves your attention yeah
okay what are my options
and then okay just make sure you
calculate all your variations to then
right you want to make sure it works
before you think you gotta wait you mean
definitely on the right track f5 is a
move you got to be looking for all the
time right
well do you have it then let other
people think yep
we'll see play out by forcing mission to
take out
so there's a problem with your line and
mainly has to do with the first move a
ch3 would not be the yes so you have to
be like what I would say is one of the
problems when people try to be tactics
one of the most common mistakes I see is
they immediately start looking for
threats and anything they can do which
of course makes sense but you want to
treat it like a regular position in a
sense that you want to in a normal
position you'd ask does my opponent
threaten anything right in any chess
game you would ask yourself this
question but during puzzles people don't
I think that people should do this
during puzzles also I've certainly been
guilty of not doing that and usually it
hurts me more than helps so I would say
your move should address the threat of
rook takes rook and it seems like a
simple thing but it's easy to miss a
move like this if you're trying to just
attack stuff so I understand the mistake
completely so you want to play rook d8
King King g7 is forced and then h3 so
what are blacks options though
the rook da check we're looking at King
g7 followed by h3
so your options are what are blacks
options there mm-hmm legal
yeah and also keep in mind you have to
tackle it moves like Bishop takes age
three there might be some trick after
you take something like this mm-hmm
maybe your idea works but I think White
has stronger so my advice on this one
would be Temple moves it's good you want
to cover almost all your temple moves
but do you guys have a particular order
you cover them in or do you just kind of
pick it random put him on a roulette
wheel go BAM well what's the easiest
method how do you determine which temple
moves you look at first put them in a
chain that doesn't sound very nice
anything any other way
yeah those are that's what temple moves
are I'm asking what order ah checks
captures and threads
I'd say that's pretty good but I I'll
get to your move but I like to be a
little bit more specific I go for most
forcing first as in if your opponent
only has one legal move on one of your
options that's probably what you should
calculate first I also go for biggest
threats so for example if I can threaten
Mayton one I'd calculate that before
calculating say the capture of a pot
wouldn't you do you want to be a little
bit selective but I'd say strongest
threats most forcing moves come first so
h3 attacking a piece is a pretty strong
threat but there's another idea which is
more forcing yes okay immediately or
after choke
well you said yeah I asked him or
question I said do you want to check
first or playoff I've immediately okay
so what are my options okay
I would imagine so okay so yeah if I
move my queen do I have any good squares
to move my queen if pawn takes level 4
like I always ask myself these questions
right not right because you can check
here but even if you black block it's
not a big deal so okay so I must take
and now what okay okay so I'm gonna take
tonight okay so I have how many options
Queen block here Queen block here came
here King here let me guess a couple of
those move you missus that's what I
thought
very easy to do you know you get excited
you're calculating your temple moves but
you have to remember like you have to
pause after each move the pause is
something I talked about in most of my
lectures if you guys come here for the
next month you're gonna hear it way too
often but pausing as you calculate make
a move stop make a move stop yeah cuz
Queen g5 and Queen g6 are both good
moves in Queen g5 probably more so
because I'm attacking more squares King
f8 here king of it
king of faith then you might have rook
da check and you keep attacking right I
can't go here because I made and if here
Queen check I assume that was your idea
right well kha did I just get made it
immediately right but Queen g5 is quite
a good move and that stops on the orders
I got it this time are you sure you're
gonna bet me five dollars ten design
what's your solution
f-five so nice for okay I must
oh the pause almost always means
something went wrong the pause should be
taken before the move not after just so
you know but keep going doesn't work
what are you gonna try
okay so clean here from kingka take it
yeah this doesn't really help you
yeah that's another one I have to tell
people a lot people forget the king can
take things you put a piece next to the
king it's gonna eat it
you know it sounds simple but people
forget that all the time you guys are on
the right track though you have a real
killer move here look for loose pieces
what's loose yeah but you don't get that
many points for taking upon yep mm-hmm
any moves that can attack the basalt
I didn't say it was hanging I said it
was loose yeah Queen f3 attacks the
bishop and attacks this move C attacks
this move you cannot attack a move Josh
where to go it threatens in that h5 but
I don't know if Metatron's a huge threat
actually the problem though is I think I
can go here seems to cover it right so
see if you can attack the bishop in
something stronger
I saw your hand first there enough
turning queen f8 mate threatening knight
takes f5 check winning the Queen that's
a pretty powerful move so that's kind of
so again like you know if you really
stop force yourself to look at all the
attacking moves usually you'll stumble
on it eventually sometimes you see it
right away and then tactics seem really
easy but on the problems where you get a
little bit stuck make sure you're
looking at all the attacking moves and
again I certainly noticed that well this
Bishop looks a little funky here doesn't
look right and sure enough you're get to
do a nice double attack there's a check
here but I don't think it really
accomplishes too much yeah
forgot your move only only the older
people my audience are allowed to do
that kids you're not allowed to forget
anything rule you remembered your move
does it work
because otherwise you're really leaving
us in suspense okay good all right so if
I if I go right you know oh my goodness
pretty bishop that's pretty hard to stop
real games to me mate I find that and
this is something I told you about how
time people forget about tactics and
game people forget you can check mate in
them game it's not against the rules of
chess to check me when the Queen's are
gone so sometimes playing against your
opponent's king is a good idea even an
end game and here you can see that kind
of is the key to the position yeah well
eventually but usually you Queen upon
and but people forget even without
queening upon sometimes you can go up
play against the king haha
I decided to give you a weird position
so the problem is first of all you want
to make sure you see things to the end
but also it's hard to count all the
Queen checks when it's such an open
board so you want to make sure you have
to be really good at visualizing be like
okay where does the bishop control where
does the rook control where can the
Queen move that's a check and you want
to see what all the checks are available
yeah okay so rook d3 is what we were
looking at so I'm gonna give a check
because otherwise you have this may prep
and you're attacking the Queen and I
don't think I can stop both so I think I
have to play check this is the move that
stumped us Oh what snitching the truth
ah not quite that that means an
in-between move so like you play one
move first and then play another so yeah
keep going
Bishop and then so now you're guarding
this square attacking the Queen and
threatening mate so there's only one
move that stops it that I can see I mean
unless you want to give up your queen
yeah
correct ah very pretty move
very nice so forth move bishop check
hitting the Queen that that's was funny
you would call it that but it's so rare
there is no name for it corridor man ah
could be I don't actually I have to
confess I don't know the names of
everything so well cuz I learned them
when I was a kid and then I forgot him
so I know what things are I just don't
allow the name so I believe you when you
say quarter quarter mates kind of a cool
name for this one requires you to think
a little differently you're not trying
to draw drawing would be quite easy if
you first of all if you don't have
anything
you're gonna play rook here defending
your Bishop King takes pawn rook takes
pawn real conviction against Robb do you
guys know what the result of the ending
game should be yeah I mean it depends on
the position but say it's just say
they're just pieces are on random
squares where there's no mate yeah now
that's what best play you should never
ever agree to a draw there you should
try to win with the rook and Bishop
obviously you'll agree to a draw at the
room but with the rook and Bishop you
should try to win but it's not
technically a win if but if your
opponent plays the best moves they
actually can draw however so if you
don't have anything here you would play
rook f3 and just play rook and Bishop
versus rook but indeed you have a much
stronger yep
first aid for computer lab horrible to
beat you in Stockton
you're thinking sort of in plans and
that's often a good way to think
but these positions are mostly concrete
what I mean by that is concrete it the
same is what you said all right so what
I mean what that means is that basically
everything is specific like to the
position so it's not like you can be
like well this is my plan and I'm gonna
kind of do this it's not very specific
it's okay I play this move they play
this move I play this move they play
this move it's very tactical so you know
a for trying to move your pawn as a
logical move to look at but you have to
calculate it rook takes up one check
King d2 or King e2 what does black play
after that and it doesn't seem like you
have really a solution because if I play
takes King II to say and Brooke f4
doesn't seem like you're really doing
all that so you have to make sure that
you have an idea to you know that's a
very specific sequence of moves this
one's pretty tricky and it's a good
thing because actually you guys are
zipping through these I might run out
ultra hard I believe you guys breeze
through the other ones I mean I don't
actually think I've run out of material
in any of these lectures and you guys
are close you guys are doing pretty well
hmm oh you want hints now no I might run
out of material you can't get hints you
guys were too good on the previous
problem yep I'm gonna just let you guys
sit here for 20 minutes I'm just kidding
I'll give you a hint eventually but not
that kind of hint that's too specific
if I can recommend a way to figure this
problem out I would say process of
elimination will serve you very well
yeah okay
yeah but then rook takes off but then I
can just take on h3 and take on a tool
yeah but that's just a draw you're
trying to win you know that right huh
but let me ask you this if you're in a
game and you have a choice between rook
and h3 and rook f3 as white which one
will you choose every time
of course because you want to at least
give yourself chances to win
rookie h3 gives you almost no chances to
win lookout 3 you have pretty good
chances to win so if you have to choose
between those two you want to choose
real carefully but you're trying to find
an actual win you got to really think
outside the box it's a little tricky
yeah
okay so look takes everyone okay so if
the rook moves along the first say I go
look do you want a rook h1 okay and if
King B - you don't get to stay behind
the pawn even if you did I don't think
you can win because I'm gonna be too
close but guys aren't giving up come on
all right I'm gonna help you along a
little bit calculate a four again you
were missing something in your line you
could have actually won after what I
played after a four rook takes f1 Keeney
- I cannot move along the first rank can
you tell me why you trade rooks and then
what happens the pond just runs so the
problem is after Keaney - I can play
which move rook f4 right and my rook is
games so you have the right idea but not
quite the resolution
you just have to tinker it a little bit
yeah rip t2 here in this position
okay so rook t2 I take your Bishop I
assume we're looking for
all right
I'm just glad I finally challenged you
guys I thought you were just gonna rip
through all of them
yeah
that's clever but you have to remember
if you don't play a forcing move it's
less likely to be correct after if you
play a king d2 I'm not obligated to give
you a check on f2 am I so our problem
after a four rook f1 Keaney - is that
rook F floor was available that was the
problem that's the one you gotta solve
but moves along the first ranked lost to
rook t1 and after you trade the rooks
the a pawn just runs to show you what we
talked about when you in the back
when you guys are in the bathroom just
to catch you up a4 at first looked like
it might work because here you cannot
move anywhere here say you move here and
I go here trade off the rooks a pawns a
gonner right the problem is that I can
play rook f4 and you don't have a win
here it seems tax a pawn the rooks for
free so the question is can you adjust
your line a little bit and find a way to
win happen solidus
yeah and then it rook takes off one
Guinea to rock up for
okay Brooke a for escape
King III also wasn't that forcing I
could play rookie forecheck even king c2
might draw
no no Kingston to does not draw
you can play rook D to check take the
reckoning for
but you're so close a three rook takes
f1 check teeny to can't go along the
first right if you try this you know the
f4 or takes whatever the problem is this
ponch was too close
you can try chasing it but your own pond
is not going to do enough damage and
this guy's way too fast
Kings do not run faster than pawns not
interesting so you must play rook f4
whenever your opponent has only one move
that doesn't lose this is that usually
means there's oh it's a line you want to
look at the question is how do you win
here yes you have a solution or a
question ok well this this is correct so
if your solution was earlier then it
would probably have a flow yeah
trapped funny position huh if there is
no pawn you wouldn't be able to it I
could has room I wrote back as a zero
but because there's a pawn here this
rook is actually trapped you can check
or do this but you just trade push this
a pawn
game over pretty cool huh that's the
solution but not so easy right but the
key is you have to really open your mind
for this one you have to look at all the
forcing lines all the all of the ideas
and a free and putting the rook on b4 is
very tricky
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]